pis la parole est à monsieur alain
marsaud merci monsieur le président il y
a il y a trois ans à toulouse trois
militaires sont assassinés parce qu'ils
sont militaires trois enfants et un
mètre sont assassinés parce qu'ils sont
juifs
mais l'ennemi ce jour là avait un visage
n'est ce pas il s'appelait mohamed merah
depuis lors cette famille faut dire nous
a surpris la soeur et le beau frère et
quelques autres sont partis en syrie
avec l'argent des allocations familiales
d'ailleurs pour faire le jihad
et oui je sais ça vous gêne ça vous gêne
s'il vous plaît et j'allais dire bon
débarras j'allais dire bon débarras mais
voilà que le père et apparaît depuis
quelques jours plus tôt depuis le début
de l'année si celui souvenez-vous qui
avait déposé plainte contre x quand la
police nationale accusé d'avoir
assassiné son fils nous découvrons avec
stupéfaction qu'ils viennent de
bénéficier d'un visa temporaire de
séjour et qu'il a demandé sa
régularisation en france sans doute
d'ailleurs pour y percevoir quelques
allocations supplémentaires et en tous
les cas pour y poursuivre ses procédures
contre la police nationale un refus lui
a été signifiée avec obligation de
quitter le territoire bien évidemment il
se maintient en france
c'est une nouvelle suite jeté à la face
des familles lesquelles laquelle ravive
le souvenir de leur drame convient comme
vient de le déclarer la mer dimaggio
athènes de l'un des militaires
assassinés alors question quand
comptez-vous procéder à l'expulsion de
cet individu vers son pays d'origine à
savoir l'algérie
deuxièmement café notre pays
qu'a fait notre pays la france pour
subir et accepter de telles humiliations
et à frome de la part des familles des
assassins ce n'est pas ma république ce
n'est plus la france
la parole est à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
sur le député marceau la république qui
devrait nous unir tous face au drame
pour vécu les familles dont vous avez
parlé à l'instant c'est une république
de la dignité et du respect du droit et
face à de tels événements une république
du rassemblement je n'ai trouvé rien de
tout cela dans le ton de votre question
qui empruntait à la démagogie à
l'approximation à l'outrance à
l'amalgamé pourquoi ne pas le dire à la
contre-vérité mais j'ai compris que tout
cela est la marque de fabrique de
l'organisation politique à laquelle vous
appartenez puisque j'ai constaté à
l'occasion de son congrès sur les
questions dont vous démarquez vous plaît
il est aidé en train de transformer une
très belle marque en une entreprise de
contrefaçon
oui une très belle marque en une
entreprise de contrefaçon et je vais le
démontrer en prenant point parfois tout
ce que vous venez de dire d'abord
monsieur le député si le père de mohamed
merah et a pu séjourner en france est
revenu en français parce que depuis 30
ans ils bénéficier d'un titre de séjour
qui la dernière fois a été renouvelé en
2005 et le premier ministre de
l'intérieur qui a décidé de mettre fin à
ces titres de séjour c'est votre
serviteur il aurait été bon dans votre
question vous le pouviez vous me disiez
ça aurait été républicain s'arrêter net
ça aurait été convenable il aurait été
bon aussi que dans votre question vous
indiquer que lorsqu'il y a le refus de
l'attribution de dunes du renouvellement
d'une carte de résident ça vaut
autorisation obligation de quitter le
territoire et que cette obligation est
désormais exécutoire et qu'elle sera
exécutée
voilà la vérité et voilà les mensonges
qui ont inspiré votre question
merci monsieur le ministre
merci merci